look who's here everybody his new
movement Colorado space is gonna be in
theaters near you this very Friday it
debuted to much critical acclaim at the
Toronto Film Festival stars Nicolas Cage
Joely Richardson and this man Tommy
Chong good to see you Tommy
good to see you you got it so first
things first all right I mean we could
go back to when I first saw your book
my children are 11 eight and six mm-hmm
they're watching the masked singer
they're watching the masked singer and
they are seeing the pineapple sing off
comes the pineapple lid it's Tommy Chong
yeah my kids go crazy they had no idea
who you were to be very honest with
that's good how you work with eleven
eight and six-year-old that's what I'm
saying I'm like a walking drug test you
better go check his room man they know
who you are now Richard Stanley you know
the director okay he was a big fan yeah
back in the day and I don't know there's
something cost me going on right now
okay you know and I've been in a few
like Silent Bob reboot I was in that for
a minute okay and in this one here this
one it was a fun fun fun job okay so
then were you the one who chose the
pineapple is your plan yeah yeah well I
I was one of the oldest guys to make
dance with the Stars uh-huh you know
they kept me way past when I should have
been gone and and I think that because I
guess TV likes me and so the pineapple
people or the you know the masked singer
people awesome he'd be perfect and I was
perfect because I got kicked off right
away so you guys thank God got done yeah
it was it was dud terrible experience
because when you're am a singer yeah no
one can know who you are right and so I
felt like Hannibal like
sent me an isolated room I'd sit there
wait for my turn to get out there you
know there no one could talk to me right
and I do my little singing and then then
that was it and then they came and got
us the worst experience right was with
Trump's it was a surprise again
I'm glad they didn't ask why you were
the pineapple that that was a nice
little wink and a nod that you were a
pineapple well they let me pick out the
classroom okay yeah in of all the
costumes I sure didn't want to be a bird
or all that stuff you got a deal right
it's gonna be the pineapple is it and
they had nice abs so it worked I guess
Roach wasn't a choice right no no was
not oh man again my kids can't get
enough of it I'm sure that that was I
was also in Zootopia too so that's
another kid yeah that was a yak the you
were the yak yeah and Zootopia and did
the oh that's Dan see what the stars was
crazy because yeah I was going I was in
Century City going somewhere also a
gaggle of about three or four nine ten
year old girls saw me and starts
screaming your Tommy Chong stars so
which one did you did you enjoy dancing
more than the singing part of it or what
the both was hell I was seven he was six
at the time man I was older than Lenny
you can say the letter you come out here
and try and let me know he did I was so
tired I couldn't even talk you know how
they talk to you in writing short
exactly I went through there you know
what do you think good it was seven
hours a day for what two months yes it's
serious it is serious work oh I know
right I mean I had a dance with all
these beautiful women and this hell
Tommy John here on the Rich Eisen show
so you trended on Twitter over the
weekend and I saw it I'm like oh gosh
trend on Twitter it's not usually a good
thing everybody goes oh did you die I
guess if you send out a text to somebody
did you die and it's and it comes back
red that's a good thing yes it's
delivered and read that's a good thing
but you are trending because they showed
you on the screen and the UFC fight yeah
and it's not just your popularity to
Tommy but it was also there's a guy
right behind you with his shirt wide
open right around the belly button as
you're saying hello in your own unique
way television to check this out later
on or just good or Google Tommy Chang
because right now it looks like a
mangina and you'll get to pretty much
every word you know what it is an
interesting selection going on right
behind you Wow somebody have a shirt
that buttons up properly maybe know your
first UFC fight or if you do you go to
many of them or is that your first no
that's actually the first four yeah okay
gotcha so how'd you wind up there
doesn't my social media guy Tony he sent
a picture in the Dana
and that I'm a big fan and date awaits a
big fan so he sent us tickets and then
he got us there I mean while you saw one
of the greatest showman period of the
sport they'd be on the planet right now
in Conor McGregor though wait Tyson well
he is beating the crap out of people
really fast and you know why hmm because
that training is so intense mm-hmm it
takes so much pain and time and effort
right that the only thing you want to do
after training is take it out on
somebody
and so I'm gonna trade all this time now
when I get you in the ring I'm going to
and that's what I did did you ever have
you ever done martial arts or well yeah
okay I'm a Canadian what is it what's
the connection between martial arts and
Canada well your fight in Canada you
know if you have a disagreement least it
used to be lemma in school right you
know didn't matter of teachers principal
anything there I'll meet you after
school buddy and you better be there I
don't know I thought Canadians are more
lovers than fighters oh no back in the
day wow look at hockey
that's her national game right and it
was until you know a bunch of years ago
where I started goalies started wearing
masks right sure they used to stop the
puck with their face right that's how
tough Canadians are Tommy Chong here on
the Rich Eisen show before we get to
color out of space I'd love to play a
game called celebrity true or false
where there are some things that we have
read and articles about you didn't you
you come out and you let him you know if
these are true or false we Tommy Chong
hit it right there
Mykelti
all right yeah Jack Nicholson's gonna be
part of this whole conversation shortly
celebrity true or false with Tommy Chong
first up you became friends with Jordan
Belfort because you met him in federal
prison you were both cube mates where
you told him to write a book and that
book became the wolf of Wall Street
that's true
get out of here yep so you're just
sitting around with him one day saying
no Jordan you should I was writing my
book okay and Jordan would be playing
tennis it was a federal prison yes he
would be have a Tennyson you come off
the tennis court and come into our
little cubicle and I'd be writing and
Jordan finally said what are you doing
and I said I'm writing my book my
memoirs the I Chung and so Jordan says
oh I'm going to write and so he sat down
and in a couple of days he wrote
something handed it to me
and because I had known Jordan and long
enough to know that he's he's a bona
fide genius it without doubt just a
little criminal but genius right and so
I the enemy what he wrote and I was very
honest with you can be honest with
geniuses mm-hmm and I and I read it I
said now you haven't written anything
then and it did back to him he's what do
you mean because what he did he really
copied Tom Wolfe's bonfires at the
vanity right and and he's got this mind
so he just copied Tom and and I and so
then he he got a little angry with me
says so what do you suggest I says write
the stories that you've been telling me
every night because every night just
before you go to sleep he'd tell me an
episode that he had in his life which
were incredible and then I told him you
got to follow the most of rule and he
says what's that I says well if you're
gonna be high be the highest you know if
you're gonna be bad be the baddest you
know because that's what you want to see
on the film you don't want to see
something ordinary you want to see
something extraordinary and so he he
didn't have to
too much stretching in fact the stories
he told me wouldn't that never made the
movie we're it's another movie that's I
mean his life was so incredible just
jam-packed with everything that that
scene about him doing quaaludes and he
couldn't crawl down to his car he had a
roll come to his car and then drive
after that so I mean so the first editor
of the wolf of Wall Street was Tommy
Chong and rejected the the the
manuscript first form to the
unbelievable next one the car your
character drove at the beginning of up
and smoke belonged to Jack Nicholson
that's right the little Volkswagen well
how does that well Lou Adler the
director yes in producer and Jack our
best friends I think they still go to
Laker games together oh yeah
that's who sitting next to Jack all the
time brightening cleaning Jack up once
to welcome friends to good use of
schmutz yeah so that's how it came to be
know what happened we needed a car you
know and so Jack said hey I got a
Volkswagen you know use that and so we
had to change the the grille of the
Volkswagen to a rolls-royce grille
uh-huh and that was the gag you know how
did you first meet Cheech how did you
guys ever I made him up in Canada he was
dodging the draft and I was I was
running like a safe house uh-huh it was
a strip joint but it was like a safe
house okay for Mexicans you know and
then so how did you decide it like hey
let's let's do it first of all I had a
improvisational comedy troupe with the
strippers and there's a what you had an
improvisational comedy troupe with
strippers
somehow the seeing can't this again is
Canada huh
I took over another fairling Club okay
and I put in the first Vancouver's first
strip joint mm-hmm and and then when I
watched I got fired from Motown I ended
up being with nothing to do it so I
worked the lights at the strip joint
uh-huh yeah and then I decided that I
should make a improv group out of the
girls and the guys that were working
there and which I did and then I became
part of the act and then Cheech walks in
learn oh and we needed a street and we
had a straight man that his wife didn't
know what he was doing so we made the
front page of the news with with the
strippers and their titties over top
phase and the wife said okay you're out
of here and then a mutual friend who
cheats word board said I got a guy
that's really funny
and so you brought down teaching and the
rest is history the rest is and then the
last one you appeared in the cult
classic Foxy Brown uncredited his pilot
is that a truer story were you and Foxy
Brown er you were not know it's a false
we found a celebrity fall take it off as
IMDB Foxy Brown the great Foxy Brown you
know I mean the Pam Grier oh that was
before my time let's talk about color
out of space sir opens in theaters this
Friday where you play an individual that
is right in the middle of the sci-fi
horror film what did you like about this
don't I like the character I love the
characters like you know the serie was
in the old John for sure
yeah the old grizzled guy yeah
okay and I like cleaning that guy that
was fun sure I loved Health Stanley the
director I had no idea what the movie
was about or anything you know I heard
something about Nick Cage being in it
but then when I got there they wanted me
to play an old hermit and I'm on my way
there with Nick Cage what's he like I
never met him
I mean I've met him before but not in
the movie okay we never had any scenes
together okay unfortunately you're
intimate with Nick Cage yeah
it's sci-fi horror film 87% rating on
Rotten Tomatoes you can check it out in
theaters coming out this Friday color
out of space it's just based on the
short story by HP Lovecraft and it'll
it's a sci-fi horror film in every way
shape and form yeah Tommy Cheung thank
you for coming on this is a total blast
I can't wait to show a picture of me and
you to my kids later on it did not tell
them that the pineapple from a single
sign of Rich Eisen show it'll be
fantastic Tommy Chong on twitter at hey
Tommy Chong on Instagram for more of the
Rich Eisen show tune - audience Channel
239 on DirecTV
for free on VR live or download the Rich
Eisen show app